we launched the Parkinson's initiative
with michael j fox and the Parkinson's
institute in out here and we have
individuals with Parkinson's were given
a discounted version of the 23andme so
we've designed the 23andme site so that
individuals can get access to their data
they can fill out surveys specifically
about Parkinson's as well as about their
general health and they get all the
other access so information about their
ancestry they can connect and share with
individuals there's a community portion
they can learn from people so we want to
have a really engaging experience for
people so that we can keep getting
information from them so we have one
Parkinson's survey now we will plan to
have additional Parkinson surveys
because the long-term goal is how do I
get information about you today but
let's say I want to know how does your
Parkinson's progress in 12 months in 24
months and 48 months because that
information will be really valuable to
correlate with your genetic information
so then comes in 23 and we on the back
end our researchers in-house are
actually analyzing all the data so all
the information that we're collecting
through the surveys they then compared
with the genetic information and what
we're finding is we're actually making
really interesting discoveries so on all
the different questions that we're
asking about so we'll hope to announce
soon information about you know because
this Parkinson's community came together
what are some of the discoveries that we
have made and what are those discoveries
what kinds of discoveries will benefit
that community so that might also
integrate with a lot of the clinical
trials that are happening where clinical
trials are happening you know either on
drugs where we can potentially help
figure out why some people respond some
people don't respond what where there's
toxicity or there's not toxicity and
some of a lot of the Parkinson's
patients are eager to participate in
clinical trials so we might be able to
help make sure that their they can find
a clinical trial that makes sense for
them
I think the biggest problem in clinical
trials is that they're underpowered and
that fundamentally that the studies are
just too small and they're designed in
such a way because they're so expensive
their design in such a way that they're
just there's a small cushion and so you
know they're expensive to run if you
need if you need a thousand patients to
really get the Clint the power that
you're looking for maybe you have 1100
but what we're finding is that those
actually are still under powered so the
advantage the 23andme that we can do is
we can actually have huge data sets
where we're not looking to collect you
know a hundred people with cancer or a
thousand people with you know multiple
sclerosis we want you know tens of
thousands so the Parkinson's initiative
we've announced you know we have over
3,000 people with Parkinson's in it
which is you know on a relative basis
one of the largest cohorts out there now
so we're looking to develop these large
cohorts and keep asking questions I
think one of the other advantages that
we have is that we can ask these
Parkinson's patients about their
Parkinson's but we're also learning
about all these other aspects of them so
we asked the general health survey and
then we're asking about commonly use
drugs so you know do they get a stomach
ache when they take advil how do they
respond to benadryl things like that so
it's a cohort where we can keep learning
more and more things from them I think
we're very focused on developing or
understanding the the relationship
between genetics and drug response and
so that could be either on the efficacy
side or the safety side but you know
there's it's a well-known studies that
have come out that said fifty percent of
all drugs that we take to have no effect
on you so what we would like to
understand is if you're given a drug is
it going to respond yes or no and is it
going to be safe yes or no and that's
going to be a critical mission of 23
Emmy
you